is it a meteor shower
base debris
no it's something much much worse
our nearest neighbor is a full moon no
more
the moon exploded and splintered into
millions of fragments enormous lunar
rocks are hurling toward Earth could
this wipe us off the face of the planet
how could the moon explode in the first
place
and if we do survive how would losing
the moon change Life as We Know It
what if and here's what would happen in
[Music]
okay so how on Earth did the moon blow
up a blast mining operation gone wrong a
nuclear blast a collision with a rogue
planet
whatever caused this catastrophe you'd
have to be packing some serious
Firepower to blow up the moon guns
lots of guns the largest nuclear bomb
ever built the Tsar Bomba had the energy
of over 57 million tons of TNT think
that's strong enough it's just a drop in
the ocean compared to the amount of
force you'd need to blow up the Moon
need the power of over 600 billion
tsarbombas to destroy the moon with
anything less than that the moon would
just crack into pieces and its gravity
would pull it back together again but if
someone or something managed to explode
the Moon
ah it would spell bad news for us
the moon debris would scatter across the
solar system
into the abyss of outer space
and some headed straight for Earth
Earth's gravitational pull would
immediately start to attract the moon
rocks
as the moon's remains start to pick up
speed they would come crashing down into
the atmosphere luckily most of the
smaller debris would burn up before it
reaches us any larger pieces that got
through would be traveling much slower
than a similar sized asteroid the damage
they'd cause wouldn't amount to much
but is it just me or is it getting a
little hot in here
the moon chunks aren't causing much
damage but the endless barrage of debris
on our atmosphere would start to heat up
the Earth
the whole world would start to get
hotter and hotter eventually getting to
the point of incinerating all life talk
about a bad way to go oh and if you're
thinking about trying to evacuate Earth
you better do it as soon as possible
the moon debris combined with all the
satellites it would destroy in space
would make any trip out nearly
impossible
but what if you did manage to get out of
Dodge or hunker down in the deepest
parts of the Earth
What would life be like in the aftermath
well for some of us it wouldn't get any
cooler the moon helps stabilize the
Earth's axial tilt it's what gives us
seasons
with a new Tilt some parts of the earth
could be constantly exposed to the sun
in the worst case the polar regions
could start rapidly melting raising sea
levels and drowning out parts of the
world
as the debris settles the skies could
look a little different the remaining
Moon Rock might cluster around the earth
forming a giant ring like Saturn
but don't stop and stare too long
every once in a while some of the debris
could rain down onto the Earth
over billions of years the moon's
gravitational pull slowed down the
Earth's rotation
giving us our 24-hour days
without the moon the Earth would start
to rotate faster and faster
we'd have shorter days
and stronger winds
birds and insects would have a tough
time surviving the harsh winds
not only that ocean tides would start to
die down into tiny little waves
the moon's gravity helps create tides on
Earth
bummed out that you can't rip some
gnarly waves anymore
well dude there'll be a much bigger
problem
it would wipe out all of the sea
creatures that rely on the tides and
ocean currents for survival our whole
world would be literally flipped upside
down
the Earth would burn up our days would
be shorter and the moon wouldn't be
there to light up the night sky
[Music]
imagine if one day you looked up into
the night sky and saw Mars or Saturn
where the moon was supposed to be
that would sure turn our Earth into an
alien world and not just because of the
new view
how would replacing the moon change the
Earth's orbit
what planet could we safely replace our
moon with
what planet would be the most disastrous
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if another planet replaced our
moon
we can thank the moon for predictable
weather ocean currents and the
circulation of important nutrients
the moon also helps stabilize the
Earth's Tilt take away the Moon and the
Earth would go wobbling all over the
place and it would cause what I can only
describe as climate change on steroids
but we wouldn't just let the moon take a
day off we would find it a replacement
from another part of our solar system
so what would happen if we swapped our
moon with a planet that is 41 times its
size
foreign
before we get to that dramatic part
let's talk about Pluto
Pluto wouldn't look much different than
our current Moon it would be smaller
though and this wouldn't be good for
Earth
That's because Pluto's gravitational
pull would be weaker than that of the
Moon
Earth would begin wobbling all over the
place and it would result in dramatic
climate change
all sorts of natural disasters ruining
your day
the moon's gravitational pull is
responsible for our daily ocean tides
because Pluto is smaller than our moon
our ocean tides would become weaker this
would devastate important ecosystems
well how about a planet that is slightly
larger than our moon
Mercury would look exactly like our moon
with its dark gray surface and asteroid
craters and it's only one and a half
times the size so its impact on our
tidal systems and climate wouldn't be as
disastrous
out of all the planets in our solar
system Mercury would be the safest one
to replace our moon
but I can't say that about Mars
having the red planet in our night sky
would be quite a sight all the iron
oxide on its surface would glow red no
more white Moonlight shining through
your window at night instead everything
would be bathed in an eerie red
Mars is stronger gravitational pull
would make tsunamis smaller but it would
make normal waves massive and
because Mars would create stronger tidal
forces Earth's rotation would slow down
the days on Earth would become longer I
hope we'd still keep a 40 hour work week
because a 16 hour work day doesn't sound
that great
moving on with Venus in our night sky we
might never experience Darkness
Venus is the brightest planet in our
solar system it would reflect 60 percent
more light than the moon and because
it's three and a half times the size of
the Moon it would force the earth into a
binary system
Earth and Venus would rotate each other
it would be beautiful and disastrous
simulations of a binary system usually
end up with planets colliding or merging
Neptune and Uranus are both ice giants
and are similar in size
a huge portion of our Sky would be taken
up with a blue-green planet
only Uranus would also stink horribly no
wonder this fart-smelling planet got
such a name
since both Uranus and Neptune are 14 to
15 times the size of the Moon their
impact on Earth's rotation and tidal
systems would be drastic beach houses
would have to be built up on cliffs far
enough away from the reach of enormous
waves
now seeing Saturn up in the night sky
has to be my favorite
it's pale yellow color and ring system
would be stunning but there would be
some complications
because Saturn is so large the Earth
would quickly become its Moon
and if Earth orbited around Saturn it
simply wouldn't be the Earth as we know
today
finally moving on to the big guy
Jupiter
at 41 times the size of the Moon you
wouldn't even be able to see the North
and South Poles of the gas giant
similar to the deal with Saturn Earth
would become Jupiter's moon
only it would get worse
because Jupiter is so massive the side
of the earth that's closest to Jupiter
would experience a stronger
gravitational pull than the opposite
side
this would distort the shape of the
Earth
all this pulling apart would create
frequent volcanic eruptions and violent
earthquakes
Jupiter's gravitational pull would tear
the Earth apart so enjoy the view while
it lasts
the moon's surface is made up of long
dead volcanoes and impact craters from
asteroids
but have you ever wondered what might be
inside it
we could find out one day by digging a
tunnel through the Moon
how long would this take
what Mysteries would we find inside
and how would gravity affect our dig
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we dug a tunnel through the
Moon
unlike the Earth's layers we don't know
much about what's inside our moon
but we do know to get through it you'd
need to dig over 3 000 kilometers
and with today's technology doing
something like this would take about
1300 years
but what if we managed to fast forward
this with more advanced technology
what would happen then
to start our journey through the moon
we'd first want to choose an area that
would give us a head start the best
choice here would be the South Pole
Aitkin basin
this is a massive Basin that's eight
kilometers deep
for comparison the deepest hole on Earth
is 12.2 kilometers so this would save us
a lot of time
now it's time to start digging
the first layer you'd need to worry
about would be the moon's regolith
also known as the moon's outer crust it
may not seem like it at first but this
layer is surprisingly dangerous
regoleth is billions of years of crushed
asteroids and moon dust
it's razor sharp and very fine and can
easily get into your suit and your drill
which will wear them down over time
and make sure you don't accidentally
inhale any of this stuff as it can cause
lung cancer
you'll be digging through the regolith
layer for up to 15 meters until you
reach the lunar crust
this layer is made up of bedrock and
it's where you might make some money
since rocks in the crust contain lots of
titanium and aluminum you'll also be
able to find iron calcium and magnesium
we could either bring these back to
Earth or use them to help us colonize
the Moon
this layer is about 100 kilometers deep
once you're through it you'll then have
to deal with the lithosphere
this layer used to be magma that would
Supply the moon's volcanoes but
thankfully it's cooled and is now solid
what would be less thankful for is that
this layer is nearly 1 000 kilometers
deep so you'd keep Drilling and Drilling
and Drilling and drilling until you've
finally reached the asthenosphere
what's different here is that this layer
is made up of molten lava
at this point your journey would
definitely be over as you'll be facing
temperatures of up to 1500 degrees but
we'll give you a special suit to help
you survive this oh in a special drill
too
now you wouldn't be drilling at this
point instead you'd be trying to swim
your way through this magma
and as you get past this you'll be met
with another liquid
but this time it will be liquid iron
which is the outer layer of the moon's
core
its radius is roughly 330 kilometers so
let's hope your suit can still withstand
the immense Heat
and as you drill your way through these
thousands of kilometers you'll notice
that the gravity has been changing
as you reach the center of the Moon the
gravity will reach zero and you'll be
completely weightless
floating in the moon's inner core made
of solid iron
so now that you've reached the center
it's time to make your way back out
through the outer core out through the
asthenosphere then the lithosphere inner
crust and finally the regolith layer and
drilling through wouldn't take as long
as it did the first time that's because
the inner crust is about 40 kilometers
thinner on this side of the moon which
is the side that faces the Earth
digging through the moon has some
benefits but overall it wouldn't be
worth it
after all this project would take 1300
years and who wants to wait that long
all right I think it's time for a change
up let's do a little spring cleaning and
redecorate our solar system now I know
you're a big fan of the moon but it's so
last season let's get something fresh
something snazzier
how about Europa
that
I love I absolutely love I know I know
the Moon is a classic but Europa could
be a heck of an upgrade
Oh and before you ask the trade was
Mutual the Moon is just fine
so we'll just Moon swap with Jupiter
what's the worst that can happen
What secrets does Europa have in store
for us
would Europa be the perfect addition to
our night sky
or did we mess up really badly
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Europa was Earth's moon
Europa is one of Jupiter's 79 moons so I
don't think they'll mind if we borrow it
covered by a thick layer of ice with
water beneath its surface
Europa is the sixth largest moon in our
solar system
because of its icy surface Europa
reflects a lot of sunlight making it
very very bright about five and a half
times brighter than our moon to be exact
and to sweeten the deal Europa has three
Essentials for supporting life
namely water chemistry and energy
europa's water dissolves nutrients so
they can be eaten by organisms this
means that our new moon can be used to
transport chemicals within living cells
plus if we moved Europa to our current
Moon spot it would then be millions of
kilometers closer to the Sun
sunlight might just be the one missing
ingredient that's been impeding any life
there from developing further so if we
relocate Europa we may eventually have
some new neighbors
so are you sold yet huh you're not well
I've already filled out the real estate
paperwork so we're just gonna go ahead
and do the swap
so imagine looking up at the night sky
and seeing well everything
Europa would light up the night sky and
be a breathtaking site to make things
even better there would be no negative
consequences at all
you the copy look I'm really not good
with this whole real estate thing so I'm
gonna come clean with you the first
inconvenience you're going to have is
trouble sleeping
imagine a floodlight coming through your
bedroom window
maybe you could just get some new blinds
and it won't just be you who's having a
hard time adjusting it's going to affect
Wildlife as well
for example a lot of rodents hide when
the Moonlight is strong to avoid
becoming dinner for predators
but with a strong continuous Moonlight
they'll eventually be forced to go
outside and into Danger
this means the rodent population will
decrease rapidly and that would affect
the entire animal food chain
next Europa will shake things up but not
in a good way
the mass of our moon is one and a half
times greater than that of Europa
this means that Europa would have a much
weaker gravitational effect on the Earth
the tides of our oceans will become much
smaller
they may stop removing pollutants and
circulating nutrients
you know stuff that the ocean plants and
animals need to survive if the tides are
out of whack it could have a devastating
effect on ecosystems and lead to mass
extinctions
okay well it can't get any worse can it
look don't be mad but we may have messed
up our entire planet but just look at
how pretty the Moon is see yeah just
take it in then I'm not buying it are
you
our moon is responsible for stabilizing
the Earth's axis
without the moon's pull this new
gravitational shift will start affecting
our planet's seasons and climate we
could be looking at a future where parts
of Earth hardly ever see the Sun and
others never get a break from the Sun
this would affect everything and I mean
everything if our axis became tilted too
much we could be looking at another Ice
Age
thankfully this process would be slow so
there would be time to prepare
the problem is we're not sure we have
what it takes I mean look at global
warming just a few degrees difference
can cause entire ecosystems to become
Disturbed or wiped out and we've barely
scratched the surface of solving that
problem
so maybe we should give our real moon a
call and see if it'll take us back
we were just so excited about something
new and sexy that we took our moon for
granted
I miss you Moon
the good news is there are no real world
plans to move our moon
swapping our moon with Europa could lead
to some beautiful scenery but at the
cost of catastrophic consequences for
Earth
the moon has been our friendly neighbor
in the sky for billions of years
it's guided us home kept us on time
protected us
propelled us into space and has even
launched dance crazes it's hard to
Fathom what we would do without it but
for the sake of science let's try to
Envision a moonless world
what would happen to Earth
[Music]
would humans still exist
and What would life be like
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Moon had never formed
[Music]
so how exactly did we get a moon in the
first place
scientists believe it started off with a
splash
the giant impact hypothesis also known
as The Big Splash theorizes that a
mars-sized celestial object named Thea
crashing into Earth four and a half
billion years ago tossing vaporized
particles of Earth's crust into space
at this point Earth was still a baby
only 30 to 50 million years old and not
much more than molten lava
some scientists call this early Earth
Gaia
over time the debris of Gaia and Thea
joined together in a dance with Earth's
gravity and formed the moon we know and
love today
and lucky for us our moon's orbit and
gravitational pull tilt the Earth
23.4 degrees
creating tidal bulges that help slow the
rotation of our planet just enough for
life to safely exist
or so we think
despite a popular Theory having a moon
is no longer a requirement for life to
exist
so could we really exist without our
moon
how would we survive
well with a little gravitational help
from our friends the Sun and Jupiter
life could still have evolved without a
moon
but how well with no moon to keep the
Earth on an even Keel things might get a
little wobbly we'd have to put up with
some extreme weather our concept of time
and Seasons would drastically change and
we may evolved to look short and stubby
you can learn more about this in our
other video what if we lost the Moon
there is however another hypothesis in a
study conducted at the NASA Ames
Research Center in 2011. scientists
performed complex simulations in which
the Earth didn't have its Moon and
measured the effects on Earth's spin
over time
the results were shocking
they discovered that the Earth's wobble
would eventually stabilize due to
Jupiter's immense gravitational pull
deviating no more than 10 degrees off
its access thanks Jupiter
scientists have also found that the
Earth might have spun backward before
the moon formed this would mean that the
Sun would rise in the west and set in
the east feeling dizzy yet our Sky would
be a lot darker than usual without the
moon to reflect the light of the Sun but
that would be perfect for stargazing
mind you we'd still have a little bit of
light from Venus to help light our way
in the dark but the Moon is 2 000 times
brighter at the very least we wouldn't
have to put up with Wolves keeping us
awake at night Farmers would have to be
careful with their crops without a
harvest moon and women's menstrual
cycles would change
despite these conditions there's a lot
more to our moon than just pure science
without it our whole idea of the
universe could change dramatically
slowing our progress as a species
if it weren't for Italian astronomer
Galileo's discovery of the moon's
spherical shape in 1609 we'd probably
still think the Earth was the center of
the universe Houston we have a problem
an idea proposed by Aristotle in 284 BCE
that was widely accepted for over 1500
years our moon was instrumental in
launching a space race which propelled
humans to the Stars
in the words of Neil Armstrong going to
the moon was
one giant leap for mankind what if our
moon had a twin seeing not just one but
two of these satellites in the night sky
might be spectacular but how would the
second moon affect the ocean tides would
months on Earth become longer or shorter
and would these two satellites
inevitably Collide to cause a massive
explosion
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Earth had two moons
despite what you think the Earth isn't
really the monogamous type along with
the Moon Earth has another Moonlight
companion a small asteroid wandering
around it but it's so far and so small
that it can only be considered a
quasi-satellite to our planet in our
scenario we're talking two real moons
just like the Earth had during its
formative period yep we likely had two
satellites once both of them formed when
a mars-sized protoplanet slammed into
Earth and shattered into small pieces
so what exactly would happen if the
Earth had another Moon parked in orbit
around it
let's assume our second moon would be
around 1 000 kilometers wide and about 1
30th the mass of our current Moon
it would be about the same distance from
Earth too just like the sister satellite
our moon had four and a half billion
years ago
would we see this Devil Moon from Earth
absolutely the second moon would just
appear about three times smaller still
it would be a spectacular View
along with two moons would come some big
Tides the newly captured Moon would have
a much smaller tidal effect than that of
our moon but the tidal force from both
satellites combined would make waves
literally
although those waves would be bigger
they wouldn't be devastatingly big
in the end I think Surfers will be
pretty happy
the second moon might stay in Earth's
orbit for tens of millions of years
until eventually as the moon retreated
further from the earth it would
destabilize the other moon's orbit
then just like they did over 4 billion
years ago the two satellites would
Collide in slow motion
because they'd be moving slowly towards
each other the debris from the Collision
wouldn't shower back on Earth
the small Moon would splatter itself
across our moon as an extra layer of
solid crust the new mountains of crushed
rock visible from the near side of our
moon would be the only reminders of its
existence
now what if the second satellite
happened to be the same size as the moon
and orbited the Earth at half the lunar
distance this time things wouldn't be so
pretty the second moon alone would
produce Tides eight times greater than
what we see right now
that would force people away from the
coastal areas because the difference
between high and low tides would now
reach 300 meters
constant tidal flooding would shrink the
habitable area on Earth but once we
adapted to this new world we'd get to
enjoy a beautiful double moon
this time the second satellite would
look bigger from Earth due to its closer
orbit the moons would also have
different phases which means we'd have
to come up with another way to measure a
month
and then there's some worse news the two
moons would be slowly moving away from
Earth and eventually would crash into
each other
this Collision would send debris back to
Earth
it would be a shower of meteorites of
Epic Proportion and it could wipe us out
entirely
whatever debris didn't fall to Earth
would form yet another new moon in
Earth's orbit
[Music]
[Applause]
imagine living on the moon
you'd have the best view of Earth
you'd enjoy bouncing around at zero
gravity and living your life as an
astronaut Explorer
doesn't that sound nice
except living on the moon won't be like
this at all
so what would it be like to actually
live on the moon
who will establish a base first
and why would Moon dust be your biggest
problem
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we settled on the moon
let's make this clear just like America
did in 1969 humans will land on the moon
again in the next decade
only this time it's expected to be more
permanent what's less clear is exactly
which country will be the first to land
and establish a base
China the USA Russia and India are all
making strong efforts to get there but
there are also private companies
including SpaceX and blue origin that
have a lot more money to spend on going
to the Moon
but wait why exactly are these companies
doing this in the first place
apart from exploring the Galaxy and
breaking new ground
there's another huge reason these groups
all want to be the first to create a
base on the moon
and that reason is money
the Moon is chock full of different
resources
it has gold silver and titanium in it
the idea here is to mine these precious
resources and send them back to Earth
another resource the moon has is
helium-3
it's incredibly rare here on Earth but
not on the moon
that's because the moon doesn't have an
atmosphere and helium-3 comes from the
sun's radiation
over billions of years the moon has been
absorbing this chemical and lucky for us
it can be used for energy
helium-3 is so powerful that just 100
kilograms of it could power the city of
Dallas Texas for an entire year
oh and it's also worth a cool forty
thousand dollars for just 28 grams of
the stuff
with these resources holding incredible
value it's no secret these countries and
companies want to be the first to
establish a base
but even if they do they won't really
own it
back in 1967 the United Nations decided
that no one can really own space
this has the potential to cause huge
tensions between various Nations
possibly leading to war
but enough about all that drama
you are on the moon
so how exactly are you going to live
here assuming we get to the moon in one
piece which is already an incredibly
difficult task on its own
you'll then have to worry about
establishing a base
experts suggest that we live on the
moon's South Pole as it gets the most
consistent amount of sunlight there are
also massive fields of ice that will be
able to harvest
some other places on the moon don't get
any sunlight for nearly a month at a
time
luckily you'll have robots to help you
establish a base
there are many different ways they'll be
able to help one includes using Moon
soil to construct bricks and configuring
them in a dome-like fashion sort of like
a moon glue
this would make traveling to the Moon a
lot cheaper as we wouldn't have to bring
everything from Earth to make our base
but don't expect this base to be
glamorous it'll most likely be several
meters underground to protect you from
the sun's radiation
and as for what you'll eat well it'll be
your standard dry astronaut food
the good news is that you should be able
to grow some carrots and tomatoes
a 2014 Dutch study found that it's
possible using soil on the moon
and what would you drink
unfortunately quite a lot of it will be
your recycled pea as drinking water
won't be available on the moon and it
would be too heavy to ship there
another thing you'll need to seriously
worry about is Moon dust
this magnetic dust gets everywhere it'll
get on your suit and even on your skin
previous astronauts have had allergic
reactions to it
it's also slightly sharp so accidentally
swallowing any would be a huge problem
but it's not just humans who need to
worry about Moon dust it can get into
machines as well causing them to
overheat
before we settle on the moon this is one
massive problem we'll need to solve
all these issues beg the question would
you ever really want to be the first to
settle on the moon you'd most likely
spend your time Mining and just
surviving with little time to run around
in Low Gravity
and besides we all know that going here
is just our first baby step to get to
Mars so maybe you should just wait for
that what if the moon suddenly began
getting closer to Earth
to the point where it was on a collision
course with our planet
would Earth survive the crash or would a
crash even happen
would the moon get torn up by Earth's
gravity
what would this crumbled up moon look
like from Earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Moon fell to Earth
the Moon is Earth's only natural
satellite and the largest object to
brighten our night sky it's the first
and only place beyond Earth where humans
have set foot
the moon's gravitational pull causes
tides on Earth tides that might have
been the encouragement for life in our
oceans to move on land
this pull also keeps Earth from wobbling
on its axis making our climate
relatively stable
in short the moon makes Earth a more
livable place
so what if it's suddenly sped up and
started driving in Earth's Direction
the moon's plan to destroy Earth by
bumping into it would break into pieces
the moment it reaches the Roche limit
the moon itself would shatter never
making it to Earth's surface and that's
going to look very impressive but wait
what is this Roche limit
Celestial mechanics it's the point at
which the gravity holding a satellite
together is weaker than the tidal forces
trying to pull it apart in other words
the moon can only get as close as 18
470 kilometers away from our planet
before Boom the tidal forces would tear
it apart all of the footprints and flags
we've left on the moon all of its
craters and valleys with scatter to form
a breathtaking ring of debris above
earth's equator 37 000 kilometers in
diameter making Earth the second planet
in the solar system after Saturn to have
this striking ring of beauty
the difference being that our Rings
wouldn't last long the chunks of our
former satellite the moon would rain
down on Earth it would be as if hundreds
of thousands of asteroids were falling
down on us and wiping out entire cities
in the process
once the moon began its trajectory
towards the planet it would increase the
tidal impact it has on us by the time it
hit the Roche limit it would be causing
Tides as high as 7 600 meters
our world would be devastated by an army
of tsunamis 10 times a day but for a
short time hardcore Surfers would enjoy
riding some tasty waves
on the other hand this might be a
solution to global warming with the moon
coming closer and closer Earth's
rotation would speed up our days would
become shorter and shorter global
temperatures would go down and no one
would worry about climate change anymore
unless asteroids burn the Earth to a
crisp then there would be no one to
worry about anything
I really wouldn't worry about it anyway
in fact the Moon is drifting away from
us at a rate of four centimeters per
year so it's unlikely we'll get to see
those pretty Saturn like Rings here on
Earth
what if we humans could live somewhere
outside of Earth
say the Moon
obviously we can't just pack our stuff
and move there today but what if we
terraformed it reshaped it into Earth's
image how long would it take us to turn
our natural satellite into a habitable
place
what would this Earth Moon look like
would this even be possible this is what
if and here's what would happen if we
terraformed the Moon
wondering why we chose the moon and not
Mars with water ice buried beneath its
surface the red planet seems to be the
best candidate to serve as our second
Earth but with zero experience
terraforming we should consider
colonizing our natural satellite first
it gets twice as much sunlight as Mars
and it's just a three-day trip from us
in short it would take us less time and
money to construct a decent Earth on our
moon
so how exactly do we engineer a
habitable planet
just to be clear we're not talking about
building a permanent moon base we'd go
nuts and actually transform the moon
into an earth just a smaller one for
starters we'd need to build an
atmosphere and here's the fun part to do
that we'd need to bombard our moon with
a hundred water ice comets ice droids
we'd find them flying all around the
Earth
these comets would crash into the moon's
surface they'd fill the moon's planes
with water and disperse carbon dioxide
along with water vapor and a little bit
of ammonia and methane all these gases
would gather near the surface creating
an atmosphere the newly formed Seas
would reflect much more sunlight making
the moon appear five times brighter when
seen from Earth
these ice droids would also give the
moon a momentum they'd make our
satellites spin close to an Earth-like
cycle the more comets we batter into the
moon the faster it would rotate a lunar
day would drop down from an incredible
28 Earth days to just 60 hours since our
satellite wouldn't rotate on its axis at
the same rate it orbits the earth
anymore it would no longer be tidally
locked to our planet for earthers this
would mean we'd be able to see the Dark
Side of the Moon although it wouldn't be
dark but how do we save the newly built
lunar atmosphere from being Stripped
Away by solar winds we'd have a couple
of options the first one is easy Moon's
own rotation would generate a Dynamo
effect that Dynamo could awaken the
moon's once active magnetic field that
would keep the atmosphere in place if
that doesn't work out we'd have to place
a gigantic shield in orbit that Shield
would work as an artificial bow shock
making up for a missing magnetic field
when that's all sorted we'd bring in
genetically engineered plants suitable
for growing on the moon's Stony ground
we'd also drop some algae but would
release oxygen into the air that would
be the start of life on the Moon
finally after many decades of hard and
costly work we'd send the first human
colony to settle down on the first
man-made planet
the terraformed moon would get very warm
from Greenhouse effects it would be
mostly cloudy too and with Tides as high
as 20 meters Surfers might want to make
the trip living on the moon would be
just like living in Florida but with
one-sixth of the Earth's gravity the
moon settlers would be able to jump as
high as three meters off the ground
remaining in the air for four seconds
and if they were really fit and full of
stamina they'd be able to run across the
moon's Lake the Moon is a giant rock
that lights up our night and can even
change colors so what would we do
without it would we all need night
vision goggles
how would it affect the ocean tides our
Seasons or our sleep cycles or with the
consequences be far more dramatic
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we suddenly had no moon
as the closest Celestial body to our
planet the moon exerts a gravitational
pull that governs much of what happens
here on Earth take the sea for example
if you like surfing you can thank the
moon when the moon's gravitational pull
tugs on our spinning Earth the oceans
respond giving us high tides in some
parts of the world and low tides
elsewhere and while the wind gives the
waves their energy Tides Define their
shape the moon's gravitational
attraction also keeps us at a stable
23.5 degree tilt relative to the sun
giving us Four Seasons and a livable
climate but what if that livable climate
were to suddenly become unlivable
with the moon gone its stabilizing
effect on the Earth's rotation would go
with it want the good news first the
weekend just got a whole lot closer if
the moon suddenly disappeared a day on
Earth would only be six to eight hours
long
over millions of years shifting tides
and their pressure on the Earth's
continents have slowed our planet's
rotation giving us 24-hour days but
without the moon's strong gravitational
influence the world would spin three to
four times faster than it does now
here comes the bad news rotating at that
speed we would experience winds up to
480 kilometers per hour birds and
insects would have no chance of survival
the luckiest land-based organisms would
either be deeply rooted plants or very
short very Stout animals
most of our marine life would be wiped
out since sea creatures that rely on
ocean currents for survival would lose
the privilege of the ocean's pull
Currents help circulate vital nutrients
from the ocean floor to the surface
while dragging oxygen-rich surface water
deep into the sea we'd still have Tides
but now they'd be governed by the Sun
and from a distance of 93 Million Miles
Away they'd only be one-third as
powerful and with the moon suddenly out
of the way the oceans would rip towards
the sun causing catastrophic waves
killing thousands and submerging
coastlines at this point we'd have to
adjust to new ocean currents which
circulating at a slower rate would be
heating up equatorial Waters while
turning polar Waters frigid these
extreme differences would produce a
similar effect on land as well since
ocean temperatures influence their
Regional climates
along with the sun Mars and other nearby
planets could also claim a share of
gravitational influence over our planet
pulling Earth in different directions
and causing it to tilt with increased
volatility Earth's axial plane would
vary some 10 degrees causing dramatic
shifts in seasons and rendering our
climate uninhabitable
most crops would die with drastic
temperature changes we'd experience the
worst ice ages known to man as huge
glaciers from the North and South Poles
would encroach upon the Earth covering
everything except perhaps a small band
across the equator
so while full moons May attract
werewolves that's still better than an
alternative world where the moon doesn't
exist
[Music]
buckle up
we're going to take the orbit of this
rock and kick it into high gear
behold the moon breaking its planetary
speed limit
how would this event flood cities
what would happen to the Earth's crust
and why would the moon go Rogue
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Moon orbited Earth faster
the moon orbits around our Blue Marble
of a planet at a comfortable and
reliable speed of one kilometer per
second
and if that seems fast to you well hold
on you haven't seen anything yet
so how could this happen
if the moon kept getting closer to Earth
the gravitational pull from our planet
would increase
that would make the moon's orbits speed
up tremendously
That's the basis for Kepler's Third Law
so if the moon kept creeping toward
Earth it would orbit faster and faster
and if that happened
how would this event freeze the planet
every 27 days the moon completes a trip
around Earth
well not anymore get ready to see this
Celestial body more often and with the
moon's increased visibility and speed
lunar eclipses would be a regular sight
but that lovely view in the sky wouldn't
make up for the hell on Earth Below
if the moon moved closer the
gravitational pull would rip into the
Earth's crust
this increased force would create
earthquakes and increased volcanic
eruptions across the globe
and don't think you could cool off by
the ocean to escape the Heat
let me explain
the oceans ebb and flow thanks to the
moon's orbit the Earth's gravity and the
Sun
so as the moon inches closer the ocean
tides would become much larger
how large are we talking
they would be eight times higher than
average
coastal cities would flood and some
islands would become blanketed
underwater for most of the day
almost 700 million people living in
low-lying coastal areas would be in
constant danger if they weren't
evacuated
but what would happen if the Moon
started to move even faster well
remember Kepler's Third Law the moon
would only orbit faster if it got closer
now if it came within 18 470 kilometers
it would reach What's called the Roche
limit
that's the point where the Moon is so
close to Earth that the tidal forces
between us would get strong enough to
tear this gray rock apart
thankfully this wouldn't be able to
happen because as its speed increased
our moon would be launched into the
cosmos
yeah that's because once our natural
satellite reached 1.4 kilometers per
second it would have enough momentum to
escape Earth's gravity
as it fades from sight you might feel
relieved at first
after all the Earth's rotation would
slow down without the moon so days would
become longer
and finally you'd see an end to the
constant earthquakes and devastating
floods but in reality
this is where the real nightmare begins
the tides would become smaller and
weaker without the Moon
any Coastal ecosystems that weren't
already destroyed by the massive
flooding would now be completely upended
without churning Tides animals that
depend on food sources normally floating
in the ocean wouldn't get the nutrients
they need to live
and without the moon's light nocturnal
Predators would have difficulty
completing a successful hunt
this could create a mass extinction
event of creatures on land and at sea
and while life on Earth would be flipped
on its ear so would the planet
Earth has a tilt of about 23 and a half
degrees
this angle of its orbit makes the
seasons possible but it's the moon's
gravity that stabilizes this tilt from
going any further so without it the
seasons could stop
weather patterns might hold in place
until the end of time
but if the Tilt increased well it could
cause extreme weather conditions and
once again the Earth could be plunged
into an ice age
yeah a faster lunar orbit could Fast
Track all life on Earth to Extinction
no that's not Photoshop that's an actual
video from the International Space
Station of the Moon looking a bit
squished
wow so what happened here
is the cover-up behind a flat Moon an
elaborate government conspiracy
how would this affect the oceans
what would happen to our climate
and could the moon fly out into space
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Moon was flat
in 2010 an astronaut on the
International Space Station observed a
bizarre phenomenon when he glanced out
the window he saw the Moon looked
flattened when it appeared in the
thickest part of the Earth's atmosphere
and those of you in the Flat Earth
Society don't at me it's not flat high
above the planet the air bends light to
give the moon this squished look in
these very specific conditions
but if the moon were flat it would
explain why we never see the mysterious
dark side and if this was our reality
how would this affect gravity on Earth
okay there are no Illusions this time
the moon is flat
so how would that happen
well a Celestial body would need to spin
incredibly fast to become a flat disc
so fast that it would rip into tiny
pieces before it would ever have a
chance to form for our purposes let's
say the moon survived this process and
formed like a plate
would this flat moon have the same mass
as what we see right now
well as a flat disc the moon could have
25 percent of the thickness but the
width might remain the same with so much
less Mass floating above the Earth the
change in Ocean Tides could be the first
noticeable effect
the moon's gravitational pull generates
these tides
our moon pulls the water on the side of
the earth that's closest to it but this
flat Moon would have less mass and less
gravitational effect on our planet
and the altered Tides would affect more
than just Surfers
ocean tides stir up material below the
water's surface allowing Coastal
ecosystems to thrive
without the usual strong waves animal
life in the oceans like crabs mussels
and snails could die off in Mass numbers
this Chain Reaction could decimate life
worldwide
and that's not all a flat Moon would
ruin
remember the tides also push water back
and forth around the planet when warm
Waters travel from one area to another
these tidal forces change weather
patterns globally
without the strong Tides we could
experience extreme temperature changes
but even with all these devastating
changes the climate still wouldn't
change as fast as the days
the moon's Mass influences our planet's
rotation giving us a 24-hour day
but with a flat Moon the day could be
only 15 hours long
but I think most of us could live with a
five hour work day
and while we'd get more sunlight the
knights would be even darker you see the
Moon reflects the sunlight to give off
that bright glow we all know and love
a smaller Moon would reflect less light
making it much dimmer that would make it
harder for nocturnal animals that rely
on the moon for navigation and hunting
but maybe none of that would matter
since it could potentially crash right
into us
wait what
yeah the Earth and the moon are locked
together in an eternal dance the motion
created by one affects the other
I know this sounds hippy-dippy but trust
me we're talking science here
the same tidal forces that move the
oceans also affect the moon's orbit
the tidal bulges in the ocean rotate
faster than the moon orbits the earth
and this rotation takes energy away from
the earth and transfers that into the
moon's orbit
this is called tidal friction and causes
the moon to drift away from us at the
rate of
3.82 centimeters every year
a flat moon with less Mass would orbit
closer to our planet so maybe it
wouldn't slam into Earth but our view of
celestial phenomena wouldn't be the same
right now the Sun and Moon are
positioned just perfectly that when
aligned we get a spectacular image of a
total eclipse on Earth
the moon covers the sun entirely in this
breathtaking event
a squished Moon wouldn't be able to
block out the sun entirely during an
eclipse and we would see the top and
bottom of the sun peeking out
a flat Moon could destroy the balance of
life on Earth and threatens every
ecosystem and living organism
including humans
[Music]
greetings future
uh moonling
yeah that's right you are among the
first generation of children born on the
moon
how would your birth compare to every
previous humans
would your body be physically different
from an Earthlings
and what challenges would you face if
you traveled to Earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were born on the moon
if you were born on the moon you'd begin
your life 384 400 kilometers away from
where every other human being has ever
been born
at least as far as We Know
the surface of your birthplace would
have an extremely thin atmosphere
without liquid water
the radiation levels could be up to 1
000 times higher than on Earth's surface
and the scorching daytime temperatures
at the equator get as high as 120
degrees and as frigid as minus 130
degrees at night
of course your mother wouldn't give
birth to you out on the moon's surface
your life would begin in a
state-of-the-art base surrounded by a
handful of astronauts
but with six times less gravity than on
Earth would being born on the moon be
extremely dangerous
right now a moon base is only
theoretical
your first home on the moon might be a
habitat based on Project Horizon
it was a concept proposed by the U.S
military in 1959 whether the base got
built into caves using pressurized
airbags or a high-tech cylindrical
airlock dug into the surface you'd be
born into an incredible self-sustaining
habitat
you'd harvest the oxygen you'd breathe
and the water you'd drink from the
moon's natural environment
your birth wouldn't have been a walk in
the park for your parents either
since you'd be the first space baby
there wouldn't be any research on the
challenges of conceiving a child in
space
but your folks were successful and you
probably wouldn't want to hear much
about that anyway
the moon's lower gravity would have made
your birth especially challenging
as a fetus you'd have developed slower
so the length of time your pregnant
mother carried you could have been
longer than on Earth
imagine being pregnant in space for up
to one full year
your birth would likely have taken
longer than back on Earth too
for every month your mother is spent in
space she could have lost about one to
two percent of her bone density
that would have made pushing you out a
lot more difficult
and dangerous
with the risk that giving birth could
fracture your mother's pelvic bone the
doctors in your space habitat would have
brought you into the world using a
C-section operation
and every baby born on the moon after
you would likely be born this way too
this could lead to one of the first big
differences between Earth and Moon
babies
our heads evolved to be small enough to
fit through the birth canal so with no
traditional childbirths on the moon
future moonlings could evolve to have
bigger heads than their Earth
counterparts
moonborn children could even evolve to
have different skin color than the folks
back on Earth the melanin in our skin
protects us from the sun's radiation and
the darker your skin the more natural
protection you have
but there's no atmosphere on the moon so
you'd live with significantly less
protection from radiation
so the skin color of future moonlings
could evolve to be extremely dark to
provide the protection they'd need
but since a lot of your life would be
spent inside a habitat or wearing a
spacesuit while the opposite could be
true
humans on the moon could evolve to be
even paler than some people on earth
The increased radiation could cause
other changes too
if earthlings and moonlings didn't
produce enough Offspring together you
could even see a new species of humans
emerge
okay well that could take a few hundred
or even thousands of generations but
you'd have been the starting point in
this incredible evolution of humanity
how much you interact with people from
Earth would be a tricky question for you
not enough mingling and your immune
system could weaken you could lose your
ability to fight off infections brought
to your base by visitors
to be safe you might minimize your
contacts with new astronauts or settlers
the last thing you'd want is to start
the first pandemic on the moon
and if you ever made the trip to Earth
you'd find it pretty hard to adapt
first of all you'd need a week or two
just to adjust to the gravity and you'd
be plagued by lightheadedness each time
you stood up since the reflexes that
regulate your blood pressure would be
accustomed to lunar gravity not Earths
be careful when jumping into any bodies
of water too you're from a place where
you have to live inside and conserve
water so diving could be hard for you
you could get disoriented and
accidentally dive deeper instead of
returning to the surface
now you could find that having a good
view of the earth makes up for the
challenges of visiting it if you live on
the near Side of the Moon you'd be able
to see Earth all the time Earth would
even cast extra light onto you
yeah the Earth reflects approximately 37
percent of the sunlight it receives so
on the moon your view of the planet
could be 43 times brighter than the view
an Earthling has looking up at you
hopefully you wouldn't grow up to be a
light sleeper who needs total darkness
you awake
you'd be constantly bathed in both
sunlight and Earth shine
well if that happens maybe you could
move over to The Far Side of the Moon
and enjoy its constant darkness and with
such a thin atmosphere you'd see stars
even during the brightest parts of the
day
being born on the moon would come with
its pluses and minuses but would it be
even cooler if you were born somewhere
else
like on Mars
well that's a story for another what if
[Music]
oh my God
is it a meteor shower
space debris
no it's something much much worse our
nearest neighbor is a full moon no more
the moon exploded and splintered into
millions of